hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now guys i'm doing youtube
videos because i want to pass the
knowledge i want to show you guys all
the different tools and techniques that
i use that work for me that i know how
to use
and i want to show you guys how to use
it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and actually how to make money on
the market
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
so for those who have watched my
previous videos guys i do
regular updates on amc and i was
basically saying that i'm bullish so
all the way so let me explain to you
quickly guys what i have here
so here we have this downtrend so i'm on
the you know
uh so let's go on the daily time frame
so here you have this downtrend guys all
right so this downtrend has been broken
retested the world five here i did the
other video with that where i was
telling you guys it's a nice level to
buy
and then we go higher and we we break
this
new downtrend that is here made by again
same technique i connect the two recent
highs in this downtrend guys
and it has been broken and i did my
video here so i was telling you guys
that uh we don't have the breakout yet
but that probably is gonna come
and once we have the breakout we're
gonna go higher guys this is
the drawing i had from last time what
happened guys i was
right so we closed just above then below
then above then above and here the
breakout has been confirmed and look
what people did they waited for the
signal just like me but
actually it's too late you need to do it
during this session all right during the
12th of march
session this is when you need to
actually um
make your long position because you know
you're going to close above and if you
wait the day after it's too late so here
this breakout has been broken really
beautiful with the beautiful way
and now we're going higher this is the
drawing the last time and i think we're
going
to 20 to revisit the recent all-time
highs
get rejected and go higher to the 1.618
so 1.618 is my level because i got it
using fib extension and measured this
wave the first wave of the move
i applied to the bottom of the second
wave and i have my ratios so 35
is my level on amc i repeat it and once
again guys this is the beauty of
technical analysis
is that 35 is actually all time high you
know so using
fibs and applying fields to the first
wave here and then to get my ratios that
i i applied to the bottom of the second
wave
i actually find 35 as the 1.618 guys
think about it you know it's crazy it's
crazy but this is
the reason why technical analysis is
working is that everything is actually
related
i don't know why i just know it as a
fact
so my view is we go to 1.618 so in if
you go on the shorter time frame
what can you see guys we are looking for
so let me go into four hours it's better
i prefer the four hours time frame guys
because you know it's
more used by a lot of investors so here
guys uh the macd
is positive green so the momentum is
still bullish even if here we had
like a bad day on the 16th of march i'm
sorry i'm maybe publishing this video a
bit late
but once again i do my videos on the
same day because i have
um you know a daily job i'm a pro trader
and
i don't want to lose my job because if i
did i cannot update you
anymore with all this interesting
information so
here we had this bloody day on the 16th
of march but guys don't panic all right
where are our support levels because
this is what you need
to spot before starting to panic so on
the short term
the support level is here guys all right
at 12.3
12.3 is the first support level and then
even if you break this one guys we have
this trend line of the
third wave that has started that is
gonna act as very strong support guys
and
so this is giving me 10 and so you have
this
level and you have this trend line you
know the one
that we broke out through last week
that is you know the downtrend that
started
in 2 13 something like this and is
also so this line here guys and it's
also giving me 10 as a support level so
we have
first 12.3 and then 10 all right 10.5 10
or that whatever it looks like a 10.5
10.5 is a very strong support guess so
don't panic we have
you know so i know it's 30 30 but guys
it's going to lose maybe 30
i don't think so and then it's gonna go
back to 20 guys we are going to 20 we're
gonna break
20 and we're gonna go to 35. all right
guys
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys